there is um intricacies to that Journey
towards Perfection there's a lot of
people that do Jiu Jitsu for decades
and don't get better
no because they don't train the way they
should they don't train to get better
they train to get tough there's a big
difference
most people they train to get tough so
they are tough you know like we were
talking before they don't practice the
weakness you want to be good at you want
to be really good at jiu jitsu
you have to practice your weakness not
your strength
you have to practice everything but you
have to be equally strong in every
position they all exactly the same you
know you your guard top bottom side
control top bottom Turtle half guard
mount back I mean you pick take down
it's and then you get into details of
escaping triangle
applying the you know triangle escaping
arm lock defense scenarios of you know
it's what the wrong thing is defending
the am lock when you you know you have
your time your arms very close to your
body the other thing is to defend the
arms when your arm is you know almost
getting and then when he got your arm so
this
so many things to practice
that you need to repeat them over and
over again until you're confident enough
that when you get there you have a
chance and you can do the same kind of
thing for even the final stages of a
cross joke from everything I mean of
course like you don't practice skipping
the I'm like with a full arm straight
because you know it's it's gone
I mean you practice
you know you practice keeping the arm
lock when it takes your arm you have you
know you have a chance of trying to
escape but you don't practice you know
okay take my arm when I say go Go I mean
you got you know you pop the arm
that is like you get injured doing that
escaping the cross color choke it's
I mean Escape not letting the person get
there you can escape you can practice
skipping triangles because you know it's
like it's you you have a way better
chance of escaping Triumph but then okay
Mount told me put both hands in my neck
I mean it's over you know don't be there